hey you're about to watch one of my
world famous music reviews because I'm A
hip-hop mogul I'm Wonder Mike and I've
come to say hello today's song is use
this gospel featuring Kanye West and
Eminem but before I get to it I have to
let you know this is just a little tiny
taste of what we do every single day in
the live Number Block on daily wire plus
my Show's member block is unique every
single day it includes other music video
reviews such as compliance by Muse and
progress by John Rich exclusive
interviews well commercials extra
stories and brand new segments never
before released on YouTube such as spot
the fake headline all while I hear
directly from you live in the daily wire
chat room click the link in the
description below so you don't miss out
it is like a whole other YouTube channel
just waiting for you Eminem came out and
on top of this Kanye song he's singing a
song about how he's Christian did you
see that super famous person mentioned
God in her latest interview
[Music]
let's take a listen
[Music]
I have a catchy
It's A Hard Road to heaven we call along
your blessings and the father we put our
faith so this is obviously the Kanye
part of the song but the angle here is
one of intense spiritual combat he's
saying use the gospel for protection
It's A Hard Road to heaven in the
Protestant literature you see this kind
of language in Pilgrim's Progress by
John Bunyan and you see it certainly
throughout Catholic iconography we are
surrounded by spiritual combat it's not
the Boomer squishy lib you know lukewarm
kind of stuff where they say Hey you
know let's just have let's just have
peace On Eagle's Wings we're gonna have
Boomer peace it's not that what they
want is a a greater acknowledgment of
the the intense spiritual reality of
Temptation of fighting off demons and
the confidence by the way that the
gospel will get you through that our
Lord will get you through that the gates
of help will not Prevail against the
church they want some of that reality
not just this lukewarm nonsense okay
keep going I'm holding on but I don't
know if I can take it much longer
today's the day that I put all of my
trust and faith in you father please let
this hate make me stronger for they turn
on me like a zombie it's a comb being
strangle unconscious when temptation is
almost like Satan is
a bunch of painkillers on your waving
them in your face
and that's why they make them in
rectangular objects cause that's the
shape of a coffin though it ain't
medication this time but the devil's
I really like that where he says the
Devil he's there the temptation's very
hard taking me away from my daughter
that's a really perceptive observation
about how the devil Works how Temptation
works the defining feature of Temptation
is it draws you away from good things it
draws you away from what you should be
doing so much sin is really primarily
just a waste of time and it's pulling
away from the things that actually
matter and you look up you say well I
just was on this Bender doing drugs and
all this sort of stuff I could have been
spending that time with my daughter
you can make on that promise like a
chamber of commerce so my savior I call
on to rescue me from these steps of
Despair so these demons better step in a
stand because he is my shepherd I'm
harmed with Jesus my weapon is prayer as
soon as I squeeze it I'm blessed like
sneezes call me Jesus
regardless never seem to be Flawless
long this is the mistakes of acknowledge
don't wish I would say something
positive on okay then I'm positive
way better with the mods than they would
exchanging some bars of trading and he
walks with shady and it probably is
painfully obvious to compare godliness
to an atheist but I got them audiences
raising gonna miss my problems I got
some awesome inspiration that drops them
off on pen and paper I'm knocking them
all Pokemon
like my side like a rifle with a
god-giving gift every single day I thank
God that's why I pay so much homage
praises to Hazel it was a little hard to
catch some of those usually Eminem
articulates much more than a lot of
other rappers uh but there I lost some
of the words but then you see this
imagery it pops up there the rifle the
black boxes the coffins what you're
seeing is that this is about life or
death you're gonna die you're gonna die
sooner than you realize he needs some
protection against this he needs a
spiritual rifle and that's the gospel
for protection It's A Hard Road to
Heaven Holy Angels defending and the
father would put our faith
not the most intricate musical interlude
I've ever heard
[Music]
it's interesting though because the very
fact that you've just got this like beat
this kind of steady electronic beat
means that this song is intended not
just for kind of contemplative
consumption but it's an it's intended
for dancing right this is the kind of
song that you actually could hear
this is really great stuff it really it
pains me to compliment Eminem I don't
know that it's sincere or not I I sort
of sense that it is because the lyrics
are good and they're not cringe this is
a man who
I am convinced is is really seeing
something and really experiencing
something that it has spiritual
significance and he's he's rapping about
it so I think it's probably sincere but
even if it's not it's a sign of the
times and the Very fact that this song
is meant for dancing tells you something
about where they where they see the
market they're pretty good businessmen
and what they're seeing is there's an
appetite for this
and it's not just for listeners of the
Michael Knoll show that's not just for
people in church on Sunday there's a
major audience because the people are
primed for a renewal I hope you enjoyed
Mr Slim Shady and Mr Yeezy if you want
to see reactions live and weeks before
anyone else click the link in the
description join the Michael Knoll show
member block to get that and so much
more on daily wire plus see you there
[Music]
[Music]